so far it seems to be a seamless
operation amazingly everything's going
according to plan the supply vessel is
backing into position for the swap and
the crane is getting ready to drag the
thruster out from under the Balder we've
got a smaller diameter cable that's just
hanging off the side here that's
actually connected to the thruster
underneath now they're bringing the main
hook back in 600 ton capacity hook
they're gonna hook up to that cable and
then they'll have control over the
thruster they'll be ready to drag it out
of the water
all right so imagine this thruster has a
giant puppet on a string you'd need to
be a certified puppet master to move
this thing from standing up to lying
down without crossing any of the lines
we need to check the support of my if
it's left or is there still enough love
I'm still tension of it okay usually the
divers have a long wait
plenty of time to relax during this part
of the swap but not tonight
the captain suddenly orders divers into
the water there's a storm on the way
with high winds rain squalls and crazy
sea conditions
but so we need to move fast
it's a bit of a last-minute twist
normally the divers would wait until the
thrusters totally out of the water
before they go in to clean out the
inside cavity where it used to be but
because of the time crunch and the
impending storm they're sending in
divers down with the thruster only
halfway out hopefully they'll keep
moving the thruster down as the divers
clean the hole simultaneously we've just
gotten word and everybody's rushing to
get in the water
all right it's go time
it's pitch black down there with a
kicking current and we now have a rising
swell and I'm not the world's most
experienced night diver divers in rock
and roll
right so I thought diving in these
conditions in the day was crazy but at
night this is an entirely different
world super intense reading lines appear
out of nowhere and the thruster itself
which was a huge point of reference for
us yesterday is gone
have a look at that that gaming Hall is
where the thruster used to be they need
to break on inside here when the new
thruster goes in but damage it seals and
flood the thruster room
this housing has to be clean so nothing
gets snagged inside with a new thruster
is put into place but before we get a
chance to finish the job the captain
makes another sudden call he orders all
of us divers out of the water
they have to get the supply vessel into
position now and it's powerful props
could cut a diver to pieces no time to
lose this is also no time to lose your
head stress causes you to breathe more
rapidly 60 feet down in the dark at the
last place you want to run out of there